welcome back to 6s $0.99 artificial
general intelligence today we have
Richard Moyes he's the founder managing
director of article 36 a uk-based
not-for-profit organization working to
prevent the unintended unnecessary and
unacceptable harm caused by certain
weapons including autonomous weapons and
nuclear weapons he will talk with us
today about autonomous weapon systems in
the context of AI safety this is an
extremely important topic for engineers
humanitarians legal minds policy makers
and everybody involved in paving the
path for safe positive future for AI in
our society which I hope is what this
course is about Richard flew all the way
from the UK to visit us today in snow in
Massachusetts so please give him a warm
welcome
thanks very much Lex and thank you all
for coming out as Lex said I work for a
not-for-profit organization based in the
UK
we specialize in thinking about policy
and legal frameworks around weapon
technologies particularly and generally
about how to establish more constraining
policy and legal frameworks around
around weapons and I guess I'm mainly
going to talk today about these issues
of to what extent we should enable
machines to kill people to make
decisions to kill people it's I think
your conceptually very interesting topic
quite challenging in lots of ways
there's lots of unstable terminology and
lots of sort of blurry boundaries my own
background as we said we work on weapons
policy issues that I've worked on the
development of two legal international
legal treaties prohibiting certain types
of weapons I worked on the development
of a 2008 Convention on Cluster
Munitions which prohibits cluster bombs
and worked on our organization pioneered
the idea of a treaty prohibition on
nuclear weapons which was agreed last
year in the UN and we're part of the
steering group of ICANN the
international campaign to abolish
nuclear weapons which won the Nobel
Peace Prize last year so that was a good
year for for us the issue of autonomous
weapons killer robots which I'm going to
talk about the day we're also part of an
NGO non-governmental organization
coalition on this issue called the
campaign to stop killer robots it's a
good name however I think when we get
into some of the details of the issue
will find that perhaps the the
snappiness of the name in a way masks
some of the complexity that lies on
underneath this but this is a live issue
in international policy and legal
discussions at the United Nations for
the last several years three or four
years now there have been groups of
governments coming together to discuss
autonomous weapons and whether or not
there should be some new legal
instrument that that tackles this this
issue so it's a it's a live political
issue that is being debated in in policy
legal
circles and really my my comments that
they are going to be speaking to that
context I guess I'm going to try and
give us a bit of a briefing about what
the issues are in this international
debate how different actors are
orientating to these issues some of the
conceptual models that we we use in that
so I'm not really going to give you a
particular sales pitch as to what you
should think about this issue though my
own biases are probably going to be
fairly evident during the process but
really to try and lay out a bit of a
sense of how these these questions
debated in the international political
scene and maybe in a way that's useful
for reflecting on sort of wider
questions of how AI technologies might
be orientated to an approach by by
policymakers and and and the legal
framework so in terms of the structure
of my comments I'm going to talk a bit
about some of the pros and cons that
have put forward around autonomous
weapons or movements towards greater
autonomy in weapon systems I'm going to
talk a bit more about the political
legal framework within within which
these discussions are taking place and
then I'm going to try to sort of lay out
some of the models the conceptual models
that we as an organization have
developed and sort of using in relation
to these issues and perhaps to reflect a
bit on where I see the political
conversation the legal conversation on
this going at an international level and
maybe just finally to try to reflect on
or just draw out some more general
thoughts that I think occur to me about
what some of this says about thinking
about AI functions in in different
social social roles but before getting
into that sort of pros and cons type
type stuff I just wanted to start by
suggesting a bit of a sort of conceptual
timeline because one of the things this
could be the present one of the things
you find when we start when you say to
somebody when we work on this issue of
autonomous weapons they tend to
orientate to it in into fairly distant
ways some people will say oh you mean
armed drones and you know we know what
armed drones are they being used in the
world today and that's kind of an issue
here and in the present right drones but
other people most of the media and
certainly pretty much every media photo
editor thinks you're talking about the
Terminator over here yeah and maybe a
bit of Skynet thrown in so this is a
sort of advanced futuristic sci-fi
orientation to the to the issues am i
thinking about this I come from a
background of working on the impact of
weapons in the present unless I'm less
concerned about this area of my thinking
of my anxieties or my concerns around
this issue don't come from from this
area I do this light a bit Wiggly here
because I also don't want to suggest
there's any kind of you know
teleological certainty going on here
this is just an imaginary timeline but I
think it's important just in terms of
situating where I'm coming from in the
debate that I'm definitely not starting
at that end and yet in the political
discussion amongst governments and
States well you have people come in and
at all sorts of different positions
along here imagining their autonomous
weapons may exist at you know somewhere
along this this sort of spectrum so I'm
going to think more about stuff that's
going on around here and how some of our
conceptual models really build around
some of this thinking not so much
actually armed drones but some other
some other systems but my background
before I started working on policy and
law around weapons was was setting up
and managing land my clearance
operations overseas and well they've
been around for they've been around for
quite a long time
land mines and
I think it's interesting just to start
with just to reflect on the basic
anti-personnel landmine it's simple but
it gives us I think some sort of useful
entry points into thinking about what an
autonomous some weapon system might be
in its most simple form if we think
about a landmine well essentially we
have a person and there's an input into
the landmine and there's a function that
goes on here pressure is greater than X
person they turn on the landmine there's
a basic mechanical algorithm goes on and
you get an output explosion that goes
back against the person who trod on the
landmine so it's a fairly simple system
of a signal a sensor taking a signal
from the outside world the landmine is
viewing the outside world through its
sensor it's a basic pressure plate and
according to a certain calculus here you
get an output and it's directed back at
this person and it's a loop and that's
one of the things that I think is
fundamental essentially to understanding
the idea of autonomous weapons and in a
way this is where the autonomy comes in
but there's no other person intervening
in this process at any point there's
just a sort of straightforward
relationship from the person or object
that has initiated the the system back
into the back into the effects that are
being that are being applied so in some
ways we'll come back to this later and
think about how some of the basic
building blocks of this may be there in
our thinking about other weapon systems
and weapon technologies as they're
they're developing and maybe thinking
about landmines and thinking about these
the processes of technological change we
see a number of different dynamics at
play in this sort of imaginary timeline
anti-personnel landmines of course a
static they just sit in the ground where
you have left them but we get more and
more mobility pups as we go through this
system certainly armed drones and other
systems that I'll talk about you start
to see more mobility in the in the
weapon system
perhaps greater sophistication of
sensors I mean a basic pressure plate
just gauging weight that's a very simple
sensor structure for interrogating the
world we have much more sophisticated
sensor systems in weapons now so we have
weapon systems now that are looking at
radar signatures they're looking at the
heat shapes of objects and we'll come
back and talk about that but more
sophistication of sensors and more
sophistication of the of the computer
algorithms that are basically
interrogating those sensor those sensor
inputs perhaps a little bit as well of a
movement in this sort of trajectory from
physically very unified objects always
sort of wrestle slightly whether this is
the word I want but it's a sort of
self-contained entity the the landmine
whereas as we move in this direction
maybe we see more dispersal of functions
through different through different
systems and I think that's another
dynamic that when we think about the
development of autonomy and weapon
systems it might not all live in one
place physically moving around in one
place it can be an array of different
systems functioning in different
different places
perhaps for people with a sort of AI
type of mindset maybe there's some sort
of movement from more specific types of
AI functioning here use of different
specific AI functions here to something
more general going in this direction I'm
wary of necessarily buying straight
forward into that but maybe you could
see some movement in that sort of
direction so I just want to sort of put
this to one side for now but we'll come
back to it and think about some systems
that are existing here that I think sort
of raise issues for us and around which
we could expand some some models but I
just wanted to have this in mind when
thinking about this that we're not
necessarily we're definitely not for me
thinking about humanoid robots walking
around fighting like a soldier
rather we're thinking about developments
and trajectories we can see coming out
of established military systems now so I
was going to
now a bit about the political and the
legal context obviously there's a lot of
complexity in the worlds of politics and
legal structures and I don't want to get
too bogged down in it but I think in
terms of understanding the basics of
this debate on the international
landscape have to have a bit of
background in that area essentially
there's I think three main types of
international law that we're concerned
with here and again concerned with
international law rather than domestic
legislation which any individual state
can put in place whatever domestic
legislation they want we're looking at
the international legal landscape
basically you have international human
rights law which applies in pretty much
all circumstances and it involves the
right to life and the right to dignity
and a various other legal protections
people and then particularly prominent
in this debate if you have what's called
international humanitarian law which is
the rules that govern behavior during
armed conflict and provide obligations
on militaries engage in armed conflict
for how they have to conduct themselves
this isn't the legal framework that
decides whether it's okay to have a war
or not this is a legal framework that
once you have in the war this is the
obligations that you've got you've got
to follow and it basically includes
rules that say you know you're not
allowed to directly kill civilians
you've got a aim your military efforts
at the forces of the of the enemy at
enemy combatants you're not allowed to
kill civilians directly or deliberately
but you are allowed to kill some
civilians as long as you don't kill too
many of them for the military advantage
that you're trying to achieve so there's
a sort of balancing acts like this this
is called proportionality nobody ever
really knows where the balance lies but
it's a it's a sort of principle of the
law that once you can't kill civilians
you mustn't kill an excessive number of
civilians these are general rules these
apply pretty much to all states in in
armed conflict situations and then you
have treaties on specific weapon
specific weapon types and this is really
where you have weapons that are
considered to be particularly
problematic in some way and it's decided
a group of states decide
to develop and put in place agree a
treaty that that applies specifically to
those to those weapons I think it's
important to recognize that these legal
treaties are all developed and agreed by
States they're agreed by international
governments talking together negotiating
what they think the law should say and
they generally only bind on States if
they choose to adopt that legal
instrument so I guess what I'm
emphasizing there is a sense that these
are sort of social products in a way
their political products it isn't a sort
of magical law that's come down from on
high perfectly written to match the
needs of humanity
it's a negotiated outcome developed by a
complicated set of actors who may or may
not agree with each other on all sorts
of things and what that means is there's
quite a lot of wiggle room in these
legal frameworks and quite a lot of
uncertainty within them it lawyers of
international military and law will tell
you that's not true but that's because
they're particularly keen on that legal
framework but in reality there's a lot
of a lot of fuzziness to what some of
the legal provisions what some of the
legal provisions to say and it also
means that the extent to which this law
binds on people and bears on people is
also requires some social enactment
there's not a sort of world police who
who can follow up on all of these these
legal frameworks it requires a sort of
social function from States and from
other actors to keep articulating their
sense of the importance of these legal
rules and keep trying to put pressure on
other actors to to accord with them so
the issue of autonomous weapons is in
discussion at the United Nations under a
framework called the UN Convention on
conventional weapons and this is a body
that has the capacity to agree new
protocols new treaties essentially on
specific weapon systems and that means
that diplomats from lots of countries
diplomats from the US from the UK from
Russia and Brazil and China and other
countries of the world will be sitting
around in a conference room putting
forward their perspectives on this issue
and trying to find common ground or
trying not to find common
depending on what sort of outcome
they're they're working towards so you
know the UN isn't a completely separate
entity of its own it's just the
community of states in the world sitting
together talking about talking about
things so main focus of concern in those
discussions when it comes to autonomy is
not some sort of generalized autonomy or
not autonomy of all of its forms that
may be pertinent in the military space
it's it's rather much more these these
questions of how the targets of an
attack are selected identified decided
upon and how is the decision to apply
force to those targets made and it's
really these are sort of the critical
functions of weapon systems where the
movement towards greater autonomy is
considered a source of anxiety
essentially that we may see machines
making decisions on what is a target for
an attack and choosing when and where
forces apply to that specific to that
specific target
so obviously in this context not
everybody's like minded on this there
are potential advantages to increasing
autonomy in weapon systems and there's
potential disadvantages and problems
associated with it and within the you
know within this international
discussion we see different perspectives
laid out and some states of course will
be able to see some some advantages and
some disadvantages it's not a black and
white sort of discussion in terms of the
possible advantages for autonomy I mean
one of the key ones ultimately is framed
in terms of military advantage that we
want to have more autonomy and weapon
systems because it will maintain or give
us military advantage over possible
adversaries because in the end military
stuff is about winning wars right so you
want to maintain military advantage and
military advantage number of factors
really within that speed is one of the
speed of decision making can computerize
or timer systems make decisions about
where to apply force faster than a human
would be capable of doing and and
therefore this is this is advantageous
for us also speed allows for
coordination of numbers so if you want
to have swarms of systems you know
swarms of small drones or somesuch you
need quite a lot of probably autonomy
and decision-making and communication
between those systems because again the
level of complexity and the speed
involved is is greater than a human
would be able to sort of manually
engineer so speed both in terms of
responding to external effects but also
practical donating your own forces reach
potential for autonomous systems to be
able to operate in communication denied
environments where if you're relying on
an electronic communications link to say
a current armed drone maybe in a future
battle space where the enemy is denying
communications in some way you could use
an autonomous system to still fulfill a
mission without without needing to rely
on that communications infrastructure
general force multiplication
there's a bit of a sense that there's
going to be more and more teaming of
machines with with humans so machines
operating alongside humans in the
battlespace and then there's importantly
as it's presented at least a sense that
these are systems which could allow you
to reduce the risk to your own forces
that maybe if we can put some sort of
autonomous robotic system at work in a
specific environment then we don't need
to put one of our own soldiers in that
position and as a result we're less
likely to have casualties coming home
which of course politically is
problematic for maintaining any sort of
conflict posture so against all that
stuff there's a sense that I think most
fundamentally there's perhaps a moral
hazard that we come across at some point
that there's some sort of boundary we're
seeing or conceptualizing a situation
where machines are deciding who to kill
in a certain context is just somehow
wrong and well that's not a very easy
argument to just start you know
articulate in a sort of rationalized
sense but there's some sort of moral
revulsion that perhaps comes about at
this sense that machines are now
deciding who should be killed in a
particular in a particular environment
there's a set of legal concerns can
these systems be used in accordance with
the existing legal obligations and I'm
going to come on a little bit later to
our orientation and the legal side which
is which is also about how they may
stretch the fabric of the law and the
structure of the law as we see it
there's some concerns in this sort of
legal arguments for me that we sometimes
slip into a language of talking about
machines making legal decisions will a
machine be able to apply the rule of
proportionality properly there's dangers
in that I know what it means but at the
same time the law is addressed to humans
the law isn't addressed to machine so
it's humans who have the obligation to
enact the legal obligation a machine may
do a function that is sort of analogous
to that legal decision but ultimately to
my mind is still a human in us
be making the legal determination based
on some predict prediction of what that
machine will do and I think this is a
very dangerous slippage because even you
know senior legal academics can slip
into this mindset which is which is a
little bit like handing over the legal
framework to machines before you've even
got on to arguing about what we should
or shouldn't have so we need to be
careful in that area and it's a little
bit to do with for me continuing to
treat these technologies as machines
rather than into treating them as agents
in some way of a sort of equal or
equivalent or similar moral standing to
two humans and then we have a whole set
of wider concerns that are raised so
we've got moral anxieties legal concerns
and then a set of other concerns around
risks that could be unpredictable risks
there's a sort of normal accidents
Theory maybe you come across that stuff
there's a bit of that sort of language
in the debate about complicated systems
and not being able to you know not be
able to avoid accidents in in some
respects some anxieties about maybe this
will reduce the barriers to engaging in
military action maybe being able to use
autonomous weapons will make it easier
to go to war and some anxieties about
sort of international security and
balance of power and arms races and the
like these are all significant concerns
I don't tend to think much in this area
partly because there's they involved put
a lot of speculation about what may or
may not be in the future and they're
quite difficult to populate with with
sort of more grounded arguments I find
but that doesn't mean that they aren't
significant in themselves but I find
them less straightforward as an entry
point so in all of these different
issues there's lots of unstable
terminology lots of arguments come in in
different directions and our job as an
NGO in a way is we're trying to find
ways of building a constructive
conversation in this environment which
can move towards States adopting a more
constraining orientation to this
movement towards autonomy and the main
tool we've used to work towards that so
far has been
- perhaps stop focusing on the
technology per se and the idea of what
is autonomy and how much autonomy is a
problem and to bring the focus back a
bit onto what is the human element that
we want to preserve in all of this
because it seems like most of the
anxieties that come from a sense of a
problem with autonomous weapons are
about some sort of absence of a human
element that we want to preserve but
unless we can in some way define what
this human element is that we want to
preserve I'm not sure we can expect to
define its absence very
straightforwardly so I kind of feel like
we want to pull the discussion on to a
focus on the on the human on the human
element and the tool we've used for this
so far has been basically a terminology
about the need for meaningful human
control and this is just a form of words
that we've sort of introduced into the
debate and we've promoted it in
discussions with diplomats and with
different actors and we've built up the
idea of this terminology as as being a
sort of tool it's a bit like a meme
right you you create the the terms and
then you use that to sort of structure
the discussion in a in a productive in a
productive way one of the reasons I like
it is it works partly because the word
meaningful doesn't mean anything
particular or at least it means whatever
you might want it to mean and I find
that an enjoyable sort of tension in in
that but the term meaningful human
control has been quite well picked up in
in the literature on this issue and in
the diplomatic discourse and it's
helping to structure us towards a what
we think of the key questions basic
arguments for the idea of meaningful
human control from my perspective are
quite simple and intended to use
basically a sort of absurdist sort of
logic
such a thing
first of all really to recognize that no
governments are in favor of an
autonomous weapon system that has no
human control whatsoever right nobody is
arguing that it would be a good idea for
us to have some sort of autonomous
weapon that just flies around the world
deciding to kill people we don't know
who it's going to kill or why it doesn't
have to report back to us but you know
we're in favor
nobody's in favor of this right this is
obviously ridiculous so there needs to
be some form of human control because we
can rule out that sort of you know
ridiculous extension of the argument and
on the other hand if you just have a
person in a dark room with a red light
that comes on every now and again and
they don't know anything else about
what's going on but they're the human
who's controlling this autonomous weapon
and when the red light comes on they
push the fire button to launch a rocket
or something we know that that isn't
sufficient human control either right
there's a person doing something there's
a person engaged in the process but
clearly it's just some sort of
mechanistic pro-forma human engagement
so between these two kind of ridiculous
extremes I think we get the idea that
there's the some sort of fuzzy fuzzy
line that that must exist in there in
there somewhere and that everybody can
in some way agree to the idea that such
a line should exist so the question then
for us is how to move the conversation
in the international community towards a
productive sort of discussion of where
the parameters of this line might be
conceptualized so that's brought us on
to thinking about a more substantive set
of questions about what are the key
elements of meaningful human control and
we've laid out some basic elements so I
might get rid of that fuzzy line because
it's a bit useless anyway isn't it and
then I can put my key elements on here
well one of them is predictable reliable
transparent technology this is kind of
before you get into exactly what the
system is going to do we want the
technology itself to be sort of well
made and it's you know it's going to
basically do what it says it's going to
do whatever that is and we want to be
able to understand it to some extent
obviously this becomes a bit of a
challenge in some of the AI TAC
functions where you start to have
machine learning issues unlike these
issues of transparency perhaps they
start to come up a little bit a little
bit there but these are kind of issues
in the design and the development of
systems another thing we want to have is
and I think this is a key one is
accurate information and it's accurate
information on the intent of the
commander the world the outcome what's
the outcome we're trying to achieve how
does the technology work and what's the
context third one there's only four so
it won't take long
third one is timely intervention human
intervention it should be it would be
good if we could turn it off at some
point if it's going to be a very long
acting system good if we turn it off
maybe and then the fourth one is just a
sort of framework of accountability
so we're thinking that basic elements of
human control can be broken down into
these areas some of them are about the
technology itself how it's designed and
made how do you verify and validate that
it's going to do what the manufacturers
have said it's going to do can you
understand it this one I think is the
key one in terms of thinking about the
issue and this is what I'm going to talk
about a bit more no but accurate
information on what's the commander's
intent what do you want to achieve
in the use of this system what effects
is it going to have I mean this makes a
big difference how it works these
factors here involve what are the target
profiles that it's going to use where is
our land mine on the land mine of course
it was just pressure right pressure is
being taken as a pressure on the ground
is being taken as a proxy for a military
target for a human who would you know
assume as a military target
but in these systems we're going to have
different target profiles different heat
shapes different different patterns of
data that the system is going to operate
on the basis of what sort of actual
weapon is it going to use to apply force
it makes a difference if it's going to
just fire a bullet from a gun or if it's
going to drop a 2,000 pound bomb I mean
that has a different effect and the way
in which you envisage and sort of
control for those effects is going to be
different in those different cases and
finally very importantly these issues of
context information on the context in
which the system will will operate
context of
includes are there going to be civilians
present in the area can you assess are
there going to be other objects in the
area that may present a similar pattern
to the proxy data you know if you're
using a heat shape of a vehicle engine
now it might be aimed at a tank but if
there's an ambulance in the same
location is an ambulances vehicle engine
heat shape sufficiently similar to the
tank to cause some confusion between the
two sets of information like that in
context of course varies in different
you know obviously varies in different
environments but I think we can see
different domains in this area as well
which is significant that operating in
the water or in the ocean you've
probably got a less cluttered
environment a less complex environment
than if you're operating in an urban in
an urban area so that's another factor
that needs to be taken into into
accounting in this so I just wanted to
talk a little bit about some existing
systems perhaps and think about them in
the context of this these sort of set of
issues here one system that you may may
be aware of is sir it's on a boat okay
so something like the Phalanx
anti-missile system it's on a boat but
there's various anti-missile systems and
it doesn't the details don't matter in
this context these are systems that a
human turns it on so a human is choosing
when to turn it on and a human turns it
off again but when its operating it's
the radar is basically scanning an area
of an area of sky up here and it's
looking for fast-moving incoming objects
because basically it's designed to
automatically shoot down incoming
missiles or rockets right so thinking
about these characteristics you know
what the outcome you want is you want
your boat not to get blown up by an
incoming missile
and you want to shoot down any incoming
missiles
you know how the technology works
because you know that it's basically
using radar to see incoming fast-moving
signatures and you have a pretty good
idea of the context because the skies
are fairly uncluttered comparatively and
you'd like to think that any fast-moving
incoming objects toward you here are
probably going to be incoming missiles
not guaranteed to be the case one of
these systems shot Donna and Iranian
passenger airliner but uh by accident
which is obviously a significant
accident but basically you have a sense
of you know so the fact that the data
that you're using tracked pretty well to
the target objects if not absolutely
precisely you've got a relatively
controllable environment in terms of the
sky and you've got a human being this
system isn't really mobile I mean it's
kind of mobile insofar as the boat can
move around but the person who's
operating it is you know they're mobile
in the same place so so it's relatively
static so I think looking at that you
could suggest that there's still a
reasonable amount of human control over
this system because when we look at it
in terms of a number of the functions
here we can understand how that how that
system is being managed in a human
controlled way and although there's
still a degree of autonomy or at least
it's sort of highly automated in the way
that it actually identifies the targets
and moves the gun and shoots down the
incoming object the basic framework is
one in which I feel like and I mean it's
not for me to say but I feel like still
a reasonable amount of human control as
being being applied okay I know that
sort of system know I've got to draw
some tanks or something now see okay
well I'm just going to draw them like
that because it otherwise it's actually
long okay these are tanks armored
fighting vehicles ignore the graphic
design skills there are sensor fuse
weapon systems so a commander at a
significant distance right
can't necessarily see the location of
the of the tanks but they know that
there's some enemy tanks in this area
over here right and maybe they have some
sense of what this area is they're not
in the middle of a town they're out in
the open so they have an understanding
of the context but maybe not a detailed
understanding of the context so the
weapon system is going to fire multiple
warheads into this target area the
commander is decided upon the target of
the attack this group of tanks here but
as the warheads approach the target area
the warheads are going to communicate
amongst themselves and they're going to
allocate themselves to the specific to
the specific objects and they're going
to detect the heat shape of the vehicles
engines they're going to match that with
some profile that says this is a enemy
armored fighting vehicle as far as we're
concerned and then they're going to
apply force downwards from the air using
a bit of explosive engineering
shaped-charge which focuses a blasts a
blast of explosive basically a jet of
explosives downwards onto the specific
targets and okay
so in this situation well have the has
the weapon system chosen the target well
it's a bit ambiguous because as long as
we conceptualize the group of tanks as
that as the target then a human has
chosen the target and the weapon system
is essentially just been efficient in
its distribution of force to the target
objects but if we see in the individual
vehicles as individual targets maybe the
weapon system has chosen the targets
potentially some advantages of automated
of autonomy in this situation from my
perspective this kind of ability to
focus a jet of explosive force directly
on the object that you're looking to
strike so long as you've got the right
object this is much better than setting
off lots of artillery shells in this
area which would have a much greater
explosive force effect on the
surrounding area probably put a wider
population at risk
so there's a sort of set of
considerations here that I think
significant so we have these systems you
know these systems exist exist today
you can ask questions about whether
those Heat shape profiles of those
objects sufficiently tightly tied to
enemy fighting vehicles or whatever but
I think it can be conceptualized
reasonably straightforwardly in those
terms but the area where I start have a
problem with this stuff is in the
potential for this circle or this
pattern just to get bigger and bigger
essentially because it's all reasonably
straightforward when you put the tanks
reasonably close together and you can
envisage having one sort of one sort of
information about this area which allows
you to make the legal determinations
that you need to make but once these
tanks get spread out over a much larger
area and you have a weapon system that
using basically the same sorts of
technological approach is able to cover
a substantially wider area of enemy
terrain over a longer period of time
then it suddenly gets much more
difficult for the for the military
commander to have any really detailed
information about the context in which
force will actually be applied and for
me this is I think the main point of
anxiety or point of concern that I have
in the way in which autonomy and weapon
systems is is likely to develop over the
immediate future because under the legal
framework a military commander has an
obligation to apply certain rules in an
attack and an attack is it's not
precisely defined but it needs to have
some I think some spatial and conceptual
boundaries to it that allow a sufficient
granularity of legal application because
if you if you treat this as an attack I
think that's fine as you expand it out
so you've got vehicles across a whole
wide area of a country say across the
country as a whole using the same sort
of extension logic as is in some
previous arguments once you've got
vehicles across the whole country and
you're saying in this attack I'm going
to just target the vehicles of the enemy
and you send out your warheads across
the whole location now I don't think
that's going to happen in immediate term
but I'm just
using that as a sort of conceptual
challenge you start to have applications
of actual physical force in all sorts of
locations where a commander really can't
assess in any realistic way what the
actual effects of that are going to be
and I think at that point you can't you
can no longer say that there is
sufficient human control being being
applied so this capacity of AI enabled
systems or AI driven systems to expand
attacks across a much wider geographical
area and potentially over a longer
period of time I think is a significant
challenge to how the legal framework is
is understood at present not one that
relies upon determinations about whether
this weapon system will apply the rules
properly or not but rather one which
involves the the frequency and the
proximity of human decision-making to be
sort of diluted progressively over
progressively over time so that's a
significant area of concern for me
final sort of sort of concerns in these
areas is around these issues about
encoding of targets I think we could say
pretty clearly that weight is a very
meager basis for evaluating whether
something is a valid military target or
or not right the significant problems
we're suggesting that we could just take
the weight of something as being
sufficient for us to decide is this a
target or not in any of these processes
we have to decide that certain patterns
of data represent military objects of
some type and of course in a way I think
what we sort of scenes are proponents of
greater and greater autonomy and weapon
systems is a sense that well as we
expand the scope of this attack we just
need to have a more sophisticated system
that's undertaking the attack that can
take on more of the evaluation and more
of this process of basically mapping the
coding of the world into a set of
decisions about the application of force
but overall yeah I'm skeptical about the
way in which our social systems are
likely to go about mapping people
indicators of identities into some sort
of fixed sense of military objects or
military targets as a society over you
know the last hundred years there's been
plenty of times where we've applied
certain labels to certain types of
people certain groups of people based on
various indicators which apparently
seemed reasonable to some significant
section of society at the time but that
ultimately I think we've subsequently
thought were highly problematic and so I
think we need to be very wary of any
sort of ideas of thinking that we can
encode in terms of humans particularly
very concrete indicators that certain
groups of people should be considered
valid targets or or not just going to
say a couple of final things about
future discussions in the CCW the chair
of the group of governmental experts
that's the body that's going to discuss
autonomous weapons has asked States for
the next meeting which would take place
in April to come prepared with ideas
about the touch points of human machine
interaction this is a sort of code for
what are the ways in which we can
control technology so I suppose from our
context as an organization we'll be
looking to get States to start to try
and lay out this kind of framework as
being the basis for their perception of
the ways in which the entry points to
control of technology could be thought
about again it's really a question of
structuring the debate we won't get into
detail across all of this but I think
it's plausible that this year and next
we'll start to see the debate falling
into some adoption of this kind of
framework which i think will give us
some tools to work with I think at least
if we start to get some agreement from a
significant body of states that these
are the sort of entry points we should
be thinking about in terms of control of
technology it will give us a bit of
leverage for a start towards suggesting
an overarching obligation that there
should be some sort of meaningful or
sufficient human control but also in a
way of thinking about that and
interrogating that as new technologies
develop in the future that we can
leverage in some in some
I feel reasonably confident about that
but it's a difficult political
environment and you know it's quite
possible that I don't see any rush among
states to move towards any legal
controls in this in this area just as a
few very final thoughts which may be a
bit more abstract in my thinking on this
I feel like and this sort of reflecting
on maybe some dynamics of AI functioning
my anxiety here about the expansion of
the concept of attacks and in the same
in in conjunction without a sort of
breaking down at the granularity of the
legal framework I think this is another
a sort of generalizing function again
and it's a movement away from more
specific legal application by humans to
perhaps
pushing humans people towards a more
general legal orientation and I feel
like in the context of conflict we
should be pushing for a more specific
and more focused and more regular
application of human judgments and moral
moral agency that isn't to say that I
think humans are perfect in any way
there's lots of problems with humans but
at the same time I think that we should
be very wary of thinking that violence
is something that can be somehow
perfected and that we can encode how to
conduct violence in some machinery that
will then provide an adequate social
product for society as a whole and I
guess there's a very final thought a bit
linked to that is there's some questions
in my mind about how this all relates to
bureaucracy in a way and in a sense that
some of the functions that we're seeing
here and some of the AI functions that
we see here in many ways related I think
to bureaucracy to the encoding and
categorization of data in certain ways
and just a very fast management of that
bureaucracy which is really an extension
of the bureaucracies that we already
that we already have and I think
extending that too far into the world of
violence and the application of force to
people will will precipitate painful
effects for us as a society and as it
brings to the fore I think some of the
underpinning and the paintings are
rationales of that of that beer
framework so there we go it's a bit of a
broad-brush sketch so this questions got
a little bit multifaceted but as humans
evolve and adapt to increasingly
autonomous weapons the complexity and
sophistication could increase with
expansion of targets and types and
target area is do you think there's like
a limit to which we can prepare against
such an epic evolution and do you think
that bureaucracy can keep up with how
fast these the autonomy of these weapons
couldn't develop over time yeah I'm not
sure I caught all the first business
question but there's definitely it's
definitely a challenge that the types of
legal discussions at the UN Convention
on conventional weapons they they're not
famous for going too quickly in fact
they're incredibly slow and in that
framework every state essentially has a
veto over everything so even over the
agenda of the next meeting if you know
if the US wants to block the agenda they
can block the agenda let alone block the
outcome that might come if you could
agree an agenda so so every state has an
ability to keep things moving very
slowly there and that's definitely a
challenge in the context where pace of
technological development moves pretty
quickly the only thing I would say which
I forgot to mention before in terms of
thinking about the dynamics in this
debate is that it's not
straightforwardly a situation where
militaries really want loads more
autonomous weapons and other people
don't
I mean military commanders also like
control and they they like troops on the
ground like control and they like trust
and confidence in the systems that
they're operating around you don't wanna
get blown up by their own equipment and
military commanders like control and
like to know what's happening so there
are some constraints within the military
structures as well to to the overall
sort of development here I guess from
our side in terms of this sort of how to
constrain against this expansion of
attacks in the expansion of sort of
so objects that may be attacked for
autonomous systems in a way that's why I
feel like developing the idea that
there's a principle of human control
that needs to be applied even if it's a
bit fuzzy in its boundaries we can use
that and interrogate it as a social
process to try and keep constraint going
back towards the specific because in the
end like I said earlier these legal
structures are sort of social processes
as well and it's not very easy it's not
something where you can just
straightforwardly draw a line and then
no new technologies will come along that
challenge your expectations right rather
we need to find the sort of camp on the
international legal political landscape
we need to sketch out that parameters of
that camp in legal terms and then we
need people to turn up at those meetings
and continuously complain about things
and put pressure on things because
that's the only way over time where you
maintain that sort of interrogation of
future technologies as they come out of
the pipeline or or whatever so it's a
sort of social function I think the
balance between like how fast science
would be like dancing in this field
versus like how fast we are so you can
move to keep up yeah I don't know you
can just be resolved I think it's an
ongoing it's got to be an ongoing social
political process in a way given that
this course is on AGI and we'll likely
see a wide variety of different kinds of
autonomous systems in the future can you
give us perhaps some sort of
extrapolation from this domain to a
broader set of potentially risky
behaviors that more autonomous and more
intelligent systems would do and ways
that you know the creators of such
systems such as essentially the folks
sitting in this room can change what
they're doing to make those safer yeah I
mean I think
useful to think about in some ways these
ideas of from the present from where we
are now how can people involved in
developing different technologies new
technological capacities just be
thinking of the potential outcomes in
this sort of weaponization area and
building in some orientation to their
work that the thinks about that and
thinks about what the potential
consequences of work can be I mean I
think in some ways the risky outcomes
type thinking I mean again it gets you
into hypothetical arguments but the the
idea of two sides both with substantial
autonomous weapon system capabilities is
probably the sort of area where these
ideas of accidental escalations come to
the fore that if you've got to you know
adversary orientated States with
substantial autonomous systems then
there's a potential for interactions to
occur between those systems that rapidly
escalate a violent situation in a way
that greater capacity for human
engagement would allow you to to curtail
it and to stall it and I think I mean I
know in other areas of you know
algorithm functioning in society we've
seen aspects of that right in a sort of
probably in the financial sector and
another such location so so I think yeah
those area those ideas have sort of
rapidly escalating cascading risks is is
a is a concern in that area again based
on hypothetical thinking about you know
stuff last question all right what do
you think of this criteria so we have
this tank example on the right our
simulations our ability to simulate
things is getting better and better what
if we showed a simulation of what would
happen to a person that has the ability
to hit the Go button on it and if the
simulation does not have enough fidelity
we consider that a no-go we we cannot do
that or if the simulation shows it does
have a fun
fidelity and it shows a bad outcome then
maybe that would be a criterion in which
to to judge this circumstance on the
right and that could also let us as that
circle gets bigger and bigger it can let
us kind of put a it could let us cap
that by saying hey if we don't if we do
not have enough information to make this
simulation to even show the person then
it's a no-go yeah yeah I think in a way
this is an issue of modeling right based
on contextual information that you that
you have so maybe with technological
developments you have a better capacity
for modeling specific situations I
suppose the challenge is how do you in a
sort of timely manner especially in a
conflict environment where tempo is
significant can you can you put the data
that you have into some sort of modeling
system adequately but I don't see any
problem with the idea of using AI to
model the outcomes of specific attacks
and you know give you readouts on what
the likely effects are going to be I
guess the challenge is that what counts
as of adequate effect and where the
boundary lines of sufficient information
and insufficient information fall
they're kind of open questions as well
right and you know militaries tend to
like to leave some openness on those
those points as well but but I think
there can be definitely a role for
modeling in better understanding what
what effects it can be great let's give
her a chair big hand thank you
you